this is another story and we cannot talk
about this on bloodspeed i'm getting so
emotional you don't even know her real
name
hello everyone i'm raja winner of season
three of rupaul's drag race hi i'm shea
coulee winner of rupaul's drag race all
stars five hi i'm evie audley winner of
rupaul's heart
i'm trinity the tuck the winner of all
stars four i'm jinx monsoon winner of
season five you're not gonna believe
this but i'm on the exchange and i'm
also the winner of all-star sport hi i'm
the vivian winner of the great british
baker
also known as uk season one i'm jana
essence hall the winner of rupaul's drag
race season 12 and we're the cast of
rupaul's drag race all-star season seven
here with buzzfeed to play a game of
who's whom
[Music]
[Laughter]
in like a fun way though i'll take it
she knows two things trade and shade
baby
[Music]
[Music]
honey
[Music]
yeah actually i really think it's all of
us because rick ransacked that place no
way she got a room divider
[Laughter]
i took a whole cameraman and that's what
happens when you get on all-stars you
don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not gonna remind you that i won
three challenge on season nine and one
four challenges on all stars four but
wait are we forgetting michelle told me
i had the best snatch game of all time
[Applause]
well she did say that
oh
evie
evie it's not for the hell of it there's
a lot of hell in it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
i'm an artist and i'm sensitive about my
honey that's all i know
you know what vacation tours around the
world the two of us and just shut down
every city we go to go so you don't want
to buy an alpaca with trinidad you said
it earlier yeah
trinity you don't even want the alpaca
with me
this is another story and we cannot talk
about this on bloodspeed i'm getting so
emotional you don't even know her real
name
lorenzo say her name
[Laughter]
well
i'll say this when i was drawing this on
my face and then stop on one eye i was
thinking of you yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh yeah yeah because rupaul has
like her like sweet little
no my favorite is the delayed reaction
when it's
in fact on the season it was you
yes oh my god
the day that um we absolutely could not
be late i was the latest
i reached a point where nails would no
longer adhere to my fingers
yeah well we could say because tina is
nancy pelosi you you kept nancy pelosi
waiting no she was fine
remember in the end everything worked
out but i put all my nails on took two
steps and every nail just went
[Laughter]
i mean
maybe help the sisters out but the best
judy
would be here
[Music]
[Laughter]
is [ __ ] honestly what you say
and brandon
where's the booth where's the southern
envelope
shane's gonna break it down honey she's
gonna be like you know what you smart
[ __ ] yeah you are so intelligent and
then all of a sudden you feel the light
inside you and it comes out i think they
have they're both the parents of the
group yeah you figure out which ones mom
and dad are both mothers
[Music]
yeah
listen y'all it's hard to be good at
trivia when you're too busy being good
at the game
[Music]
see why we said she'd raised you for
november
and make sure to watch rupaul's drag
race all-star seven may 20th on
paramount plus
[Music]
you